hey everybody just want to give a quick
introduction before I get into the
gameplay parts of this video about two
weeks ago I was invited to an event by
frontier in Hollywood where at Universal
Studios they showed off jurassic world
to a bunch of press and youtubers and it
included one hour of gameplay along with
a developer at your site to help you
with whatever you needed and this was
all recorded for turning it into a video
of some sorts and I have to be very
honest I didn't really keep that in mind
at the moment I was just trying to spend
that hour learning as much about the
game as possible and trying as many
things as I could so I didn't really
focus so much on making this video in
its own so there's not much of a great
structure to this and I edited a lot of
stuff out of this just to keep the more
important bits in any case unlike many
of the youtubers and press at the event
I don't have any prior experience
playing dinosaur games except for maybe
Zoo Tycoon but that's quite a stretch so
my focus here was really on seeing what
extent this game is intuitive and how
easy it is to actually pick this up and
honestly also how much I am into playing
it and how much fun it was to play it as
somebody who's more of an outsider in
these kinds of games then really a big
drastic Road fan because I think
undoubtedly anybody who is a big fan of
the Jurassic Park franchise is gonna
like this game honestly and at the very
least gonna want to try this game for
themselves but for a lot of people like
me who have never been that much into it
just kind of like the movies but never
really been part of that community I
thought it was interesting to see you
know how much this this game really work
so that will be a focus also there's one
thing that I do wanna say and that is
that this is probably my fault I have no
idea what happened but somehow I messed
up the audio there so that the audio
that I gots that was later sent has my
microphone really loud so it's kind of
clipping at many points so I'm very
sorry for the horrible audio I try to
cut out my dialogue as much as possible
but it still is a little bit annoying
every now and then in any case I don't
want to make this introduction much
longer I'll end this video with some of
my closing thoughts and a bit of a read
you of my experience but for now let's
just get into the gameplay it's gonna be
a little bit of a tutorial to start with
right um and at the end of the tutorial
you're going to be given one of the
story missions so I don't know whether
you want to see sort of some of the
gameplay or something exciting or we
want to get like a dangerous dinosaur
that we could do some fun things with or
whether you just monster didn't like
park construction but basically
depending on which one you want to
choose we can we can pick that sort of
as you get to that point babe now I just
I just want to learn and see as much as
I can and you were the senior designer
right so what kind of stuff that you
work on so I'm kind of one of my my main
things is the the missions the contracts
things a little bit mm-hmm
so I got to work quite closely with
Johnny's platitudes that is the right
house mm-hmm
put together the framework for that
write a story we need for the story for
the story I think it's my job to say we
need lines for this this is this right
right away make it that's really cool he
nice but also I kind of had it had sort
of that would in in a bit of everything
mm-hmm we kind of tend to dip our toes
into lots of different jobs
mm-hmm yeah honestly I don't even know
where to start so start with so just
follow the steps as you into that makes
a lot of sense to creation now which is
where you incubate what your dinosaurs
say all right so we've got the UI over
here so this is where it's trying to get
me to go all right now you can only
follow this path right freights Marlin
somewhere around here
should I remove some of those stuff that
I have here no you won't need to do that
for now you just need to block that down
into that's it once it goes blue is sort
of a valid placement ah right yes that's
the one and only time we I think so you
need to do is same again following the
flesh you like mashing icon and connect
the path up to
yeah past work a bit differently a
planet coaster and this one this one is
sort of a clicking and then we dragon
and toggle between curved parts and non
curved pass with spacebar with the
spacebar yeah right all right
got one by clicking on the lab then yeah
so that's the building we just created
and then we go to a hatching by an
incubator dinosaur hi guys you got it so
for now you've got some genome for
various dinosaurs but you need to have a
minimum of 50% of all you action prior
dies right that makes sense it all makes
sense
release the dinosaur I guess we could
just go ahead and do that it seems like
the whole pen over here is good are
these and these animations are
absolutely insane I remember watching
the demo and looking at this kind of
information and like thinking that this
was like a cutscene or something that
was like completely prepared and
animated beforehand and at the end of
this clip I totally forgot that it was
still in game footage very sweet
universe where they go MF Ernst material
sits off work way so we can make this
possible and you know the guys in the
animation team when you are seeing stuff
and the audio guys that's amazing yeah
this is crazy like this is not just the
movie you've seen this is just me moving
the camera right now you can see but you
can also if you click on the vs. STR
0:02 up there yeah that was one of the
questions that I had before I play this
and I haven't seen anybody honest to
this yet but are all the dinosaurs also
female oh say that's good so we are
following the Jurassic Lauren yeah at
least the advantage of that is is not
accidentally calling a guy Angela that
would have been horrible yeah she's like
come here
guru and he's kind of there to help ease
your way through the game and he he sort
of just just give me some information on
the various divisions we've got right
and this is the point where we are 410
for the purposes of the tutorial we're
kind of locking you a little bit to one
of these divisions so depending on what
you want to see or want something you
might want to get out for your video and
there's kind of three quite different
experiences here so for example the
science contract deals in vastrel
disease and curing and dinosaur
entertainment gives you a Ceratosaurus
at the end of it which is a carnivore so
if you wanted for example to create some
havoc that would be a good choice right
the security mission is is it's a bit
different in the sense that you actually
want they actually want you to work
let's one loose oh so make you a choice
actually that was one of the things that
I wanted to ask what happens when a
dinosaur it gets loose how are you gonna
have to we can find out so we've got two
ways we can find out we can either go
entertainment and then whilst the story
mission won't ask us to do that we can
do that anyway mm-hmm the other one is
the the security mission itself and that
one actually wants you to do as part of
the mission so right I think I'll try
the entertainment so they kind of get
the best of both worlds I feel this is a
contract and as the guys so the demo
these are kind of like a small jobs or
tasks you can you can complete in return
for some cash and mutation and
reputation is very important because
reputation unlock story missions and
rewards and sort of helps you all
progression right right all right
I'll accept that then so what you can
see here is the outline of your sort of
power network so these two regional
roads are areas where power is provided
mm-hm hair is sort of produced at a
power station mm-hm that is then
transported around your park via pylons
and then to a substation which is that
little building you can see just there
and that what that does is that turns
the power it's something the buildings
can use in terms of the rainiest so a
building just needs to be touching the
radius in order to receive power okay
right assuming you have enough yeah is
it fine I'm a power generated but I
guess for now we'll be fine exactly yeah
you should be fine we'll soon find out
if we're
right try and connect that then what
play around with the paths a little bit
if I remember correctly you can like
make them cook oh that's really easy oh
and it is much easier to do them
planning it goes through yeah yeah I
think that's that's really easy to do
we're kind of trying to find a nice
balance between something that's
intuitive we're playing with the
controller and eating you know easy to
grasp but also you know Elijah Steve
yeah Artie put some more unique path
layouts than just kind of like that all
paths winding everywhere exactly that's
really crying you've just completed your
first contract some reputation which is
also reflected in the little bars at the
bottom right and then the left is
science and the right is like danger
yeah right oh yeah that's gonna be
dangerous
that's a lot of money so yeah asteroid
missions are definitely worth doing cuz
the rewards are worth it 90 we get you
know large sums of cash but you'll get
other other rewards as well in this
instance it's a um a cosmetic gene but
they're different missions have
different rewards so in order to get
some more genome mm-hmm you're gonna
need to send your dick team out to get
some fossils uh-huh to do that you need
to you can either go to your control
room or going directly to the building
whichever whichever is easiest all right
and then from there you can go to the
the globe icon is your expedition map so
it's showing all the exclamation points
for the things that are of interest
their sites that you've got access to at
the moment and if you mouse over them
you'll see that there are different
fossils that can be found at each and I
would recommend going and looking in
Europe for a circle okay what's it'd be
sort of a Algarve is there any
particular country that there's not much
choice oh yeah the rest is still like
the UK sites and but they they get
unlocked as you progress through the
game and there we go so what you're
finding it now is that your health
has taken off from your expedition
Center and then he will head off for now
go and perform this mission and they
will return once they've got some
possums that's very cool
I just want to kind of explore around
here is going on so my rating is very
low because I don't really have any
dinos yet you can click on you can click
on each of these these like buttons and
they can give you a breakdown of how
you're sort of rating is is calculated
right right again these these can be
clicked on to get some additional
information too so this this interfaces
are fossil sensor interface right here
is where we extract the DNA from all of
our the fossils that we find so as you
can see you've already got a selection
of fossils here and you can start
extracting the DNA from them in order to
start you know building up your genome
so for example here you've got the UM
struthiomimus fossil highlighted because
you already had fifty percent of the
genome directing this fossil will give
you an additional twelve percent
okay and there's no reason basically not
to extract the DNA from these guys yeah
exactly just click all these things and
expect them yeah yeah and you can queue
them up so no do one at a time right the
one we're interested in the moment is
the one on the right which is the yes
yeah it's definitely so we should
definitely expect that and is it also a
good idea to sell some of your fossils
so probably not initially and what
you'll find is that as you perform digs
you won't always get fossils back
sometimes you get some rare metals or
and other elements that can be sold for
cash and once you kind of got high
percentage of the genome and maybe a few
a bit long cash in there selling a
fossil is an option but usually probably
more worthwhile to were to extract their
DNA first right right but it's an option
you can this I think to stop you doing
it okay yeah it's an interesting option
and I see an exclamation point here an
engine database which is like an
information repository so as you uncover
things in the game and research new
things or acquire new dinosaurs you
unlock some some more detailed
information about it so when we I think
when we accrue enough
I know DNA or me retrieve some fossils
from a dig site will actually get some
more additions so like your dinosaur a
section which will give you a like a
history on the dinosaur where the first
fossils right right some kind of useful
trivia and information that and but you
know for those that wants it
okay I think something just happened on
the fossils oh wow oh yeah let's get
that
quick and even more yeah but as I said
there we go there's a non-fossil big
fine which you can be sold so by the
looks of it if you get like a mosquito
in amber it's much more efficient than
fossils when it comes to adding to you
you know exactly the kind of the Amber's
that's that's the best thing to [ __ ]
yeah right but again it's still it's in
your interest to try and get the higher
the genome the better the dinosaur
mm-hmm okay
so I should definitely expect this while
I'm at it as well right right no
dinosaur DNA tech strikes so I could
just sell this yeah Lester rhodium says
Justin only can we have enough so you
can hit escape we can buy eggs up there
all right
that is definitely dr. Ian Malcolm
speaking yeah hmm but would it first be
a good idea to try and build their whole
keep first or you can do whatever you
want mean you at the moment you've got
one dinosaur in that enclosure excuse me
- and if you were you know that way
inclines he could be considered a snack
yeah she rather Angela depends if we
want Angela to get munched on and she's
also so you just as you clicked so now
you can see that she's in an agitated
state in the moment because her social
need is low all right yeah that's a
little bit sad that's true so we can
always make a friend for her mm-hmm or
indeed you can create yourself an
enclosure for your for your Ceratosaurus
elsewhere if you want to keep things
safe and so this is my first time ever
using this some really curious to see
how this all works okay so this is the
removing tool just kind of remove
everything so is there like a limit to
the map there is yeah as you can see
there's you the I guess first built the
the fencing around its enclosures and
this is just the only fence that I can
get to actually find is if you click on
the fence it opens up and all right at
the moment you do
you have access to the light steel fence
but yes for the game you can get access
to right sort of stronger fences and
different different types right and as
per the paths spacebar allows you to do
perform curves yeah
ah that's that's really handy so you
want to get it a little bit more curved
so there's like a maximum length to it
but there is yeah Jeremy as a rule is if
you try and build to your cursor so if
you put your cursor where you want your
you're sort of Yorker to end up mm-hmm
it will then kind of try and conform to
the point you you've right right yes
rather than strictly being sort of piece
by piece placement you're kind of you're
leading it round yeah yeah that's quite
easy to use
definitely and I noticed for the path as
well it was just a narrow path but does
that mean that you get other paths as
you go further into the game do you
might even have access to them now in
fact now you've got this tutorial
session I should be alright expensive
parser can have like positive impacts
right populates with things like
cyanogen mm-hmm lighting in session oh
this is really cool the way that you can
just kind of make plazas this way you
could create some really awesome shapes
with that I've really loved that path
tool so far it's really easy to use so
as for the rest of the landscaping I've
heard that you do need some kind of
water source you know your diners to
drink in ah
right let's get to this tool with the
water right uh automatically sort of
creates a pond around it as well that's
easy enough right so I dunno and a
transition this a little bit more and
what other tools do we have here flatten
and smooth oh that's perfect I'm glad
that there's a smooth tool for the
terraforming yep
and I guess I need a little bit of
forest for my dinosaur design
yeah so if and darkness was like
different amounts of sort of forest or
cover and their habitat so it's kind of
bad dinosaur dependent right right it's
definitely a new interest
there's something that and then we've
also got shrubs which looks really
interesting it's really easy to do like
a lot of foliage this way is what I've
noticed since the maps are so big and in
planet coaster you very easily spend a
lot of time just putting trees
everywhere that's right but with these
brushes it works out quite well how do I
like go further how do I get my dinosaur
in this segment you've got two options
one one is to build a hamon creation lab
and actually attach it to this enclosure
so you can really start a source
straight into here mm-hmm
you know the other option is to build a
building called an ACU Center and which
is the asset containment unit Center so
that that building comes with a
helicopter and oh yeah and they allow
you to try dinosaurs and you can
transport them that sounds like the
better option
sounds of enclosure sounds like it's a
better idea than just getting a hammock
Center and having the Center for every
single key be she'd be a space bar she'd
also toggle angle snap so you can do
free rotation oh good point right right
so if I get space bar I can just ah
that's perfect
all right so this part should be hooked
up yep we now have an ICU center with
our helicopter so we can tranquilize
dinosaurs and now we've got 50% at least
of our starts a source yes so time to
incubate you yeah we can incubate one in
there we can release the street here -
all right
she comes as a friend for Angela she
looks about the same as Angela but are
they also like possibilities of getting
like the gene mutations to finally end
up with males or you can modify the
genes in a number of ways in terms of
changing the appearance you there are
some cosmetic options in terms of skins
mm-hm most of the modification allow you
to basically modify the dinosaur base
stats right right but there are some
modifications that make like slightly
different looking dinosaurs so there are
modifications do they change the skins
of dinosaurs right right yes a different
variation oh that's really cool on there
all right yes drink so hopefully you
should find that Angela's a bit
here now as well I should got afraid
where she is one thing you could also do
is you can pop into the schematic view
which is the map one oh yeah you find
your dinosaurs and see sort of oh and
one thing that I did just notice if you
press the r button again is that she's
hungry oh very good point so I need to
place some sort of food thing in here
right and these are herbivores right
great
yeah so definitely something lower like
this by the looks of it yeah Wow yeah to
meet or to a giant tree all right I'll
get something like this looks like they
are already reading each other it
definitely looks like they're having a
chat all right so should that be fine
for the both of them or all right yeah
what you're fine is good feeders sort of
replace themselves over time eventually
they can run out and they need to be
it's placed right right something your
ranger teams can do in the meantime it
might be good idea to put some food yeah
for the further people actually or
people or for your for your Ceratosaurus
winner right right she arrives so we can
already oh wait in enclosures put up a
live bait or so carnivores have
additional needs that pebbles don't one
of those needs is a hunting need right
if you put down a live sort of faked
feeder but you're fine is that that can
satisfy oh okay doesn't always but it
can right right well well get that in
there then there's a giant monorail that
brings the guests to the park I see oh
yeah
so currently you haven't got that many
yes in your Park
yeah that's primarily because we don't
have that many dinosaurs it's not much
in the way of an attractions for them to
see so one thing we could do in an
equally your diet your guests can't
actually see your dinosaurs but you've
got no viewing gallery on your right
right your enclosure so that's something
we could do is add a viewing gallery and
they just don't snap to the fence like
that are perfect
and then as per usual they need to be
connected to the path and this one also
needs to have some power supply to it
because it's outside of one of those
sort of radiuses or roads in order so
that's it and then we need to place down
a substation okay
so it's small oh yes substation so again
substation is create that you sort of
turn the power yeah right right so you
can pop on those and that just needs to
be connected to the pylon Network all
right there we go so when that's
finished you should find that your
gallery is powered and ready to roll
great and I think we also need some food
for the people maybe there's not much
for the visitors good idea and there's
something and you can do actually here
to see kind of how how your guests needs
are looking and the things they want and
that's done if you click on the eyeball
I got on the left there I wrote my
management views and there's a load of
options here that lets you sort of see a
visual representation of the
satisfaction of your guests one so for
example if you click on the burger which
is a food satisfaction so what you're
seeing here is basically guests around
around these areas are unsatisfied
because your food coverage is a zero
percent mm-hmm if we were to build a
fast-food restaurant nearby what you'll
see then is that that satisfaction level
should change right right well I have
plenty of money so I'm just gonna put
this some oh you can even snap them to
support these buildings do snap to past
these are kind of special
oh yeah snap directly to them that's
good alright so I also love the
animations on how you actually get all
of the scaffolding and stuff going on
around it it's really cool so in the
meantime can we check on the incubator
and see what's oh I didn't hatch
anything yeah whoops oh that's expensive
yeah Wow she's yeah definitely it's
going to be worth it to let it loose on
the guests and see what's gonna happen I
think I have no idea what's gonna happen
with that it's not also like one of the
core mechanics of the game so definitely
sort of calamities are a thing and
you know accidents can happen and
dinosaurs can escape you know much like
the films it's you know you're trying to
build a very successful park but
inevitably something's probably gonna go
wrong yeah you can try and mitigate it
and try and plan against it but life's
gonna find a way it's definitely plain
you find that it's not it's not just you
know dinosaurs escaping but also things
like the weather could have an impact on
game yeah yeah things can get damaged
your power lines can drop out and lots
of lots of challenges for you to sort of
deal with and as you profess for the
game progressed through the game sorry
later Islands sort of come with more
challenges and difficult things for you
to deal with so it's it also going to be
like having an effect on how well your
Park is gonna be like in terms of
whether people are gonna want to visit
it so for instance if you have like a
big event and like one of the dinosaurs
breaks loose and kills five people well
that also mean that nobody wants to
visit your pocket no yes in essence yes
what you'll find is that you're part
racing will take a hit mmm-hmm no you're
part racing the less yes but we want to
visit but also you get a financial hit
in the form of lawsuits because our
roads your PR man mr. Finch will try its
hardest to work yeah you know keep such
events quiet but you cost money so is
there any way to like check on the
progress
so that Germany Duss were the bigger and
more impressive dinosaurs tend to take
longer to to incubate versus like let's
choose - which is relatively speedy
right right that's okay I mean in the
meantime we can and we've already so we
already created in there a new enclosure
but we've got some fossils there that
needs needed some attention we can
request a contract of lots do cements
work for a different division mm-hm we
can build some new more buildings I mean
it's up to you really yeah so how do you
strike up a contract somewhere so if you
go to the the first tab up there mm-hmm
which is the management view so
contracts is your right panel all right
and in here you get the option to so so
sometimes the divisions will approach
you with with an offer of work and
sometimes you can request the contracts
so if you click that it should let you
choose one of the divisions you can say
yeah I would like to
receive a contract from so it's right
security and then you'll receive an
offer perform a successful expedition to
the excites so there you go this is
relatively relatively easy a contract
and it's going to probably something
you're gonna do anyway so it's definite
in your interest to sort of seek out
contracts and what you'll find is that
as you progress through the game
contracts will get harder yeah yeah and
I'm also a little bit curious for the
intern database is this also something
that might help you out by being able to
check the dinosaurs and see what their
weaknesses are or we can create one we
can get some some stats we can see that
there's nine Muses long it weighed a ton
it's kind of all there's no where as
first discovered and such and there's
some kind of information and tidbits in
there but there are some things which
you really just have to like kind of
figure out on your own as in like what
kind of keep should I keep it in what
other dinosaurs is it ok with
self-discovery in there right right we
don't spoil everything God uses
something sort of a surprise and I mean
obviously common sense paid into it a
little bit yeah carnivores in with
herbivores it's probably not going well
or equally you know some kind of wars
are surrounding social and they're very
very territorial so you'll find that
they can actually come to blows as well
and in fact I had I had someone someone
playing earlier who wanted to know if we
could create a it's a dinosaur combat
arena and just watch them guys which
which you know in theory you can't
there's nothing to stop you the idea is
to release her and then instantly to
resolve we can release her and then we
can fit your ACU chopper to come and
tranquilize I hopefully before she
causes any rights so there's two ways
you can do that you can either take
control of the helicopter manually as
the guys did in the MMO or you can
actually request right right do you
think it might help if I just put them
in some meats in the enclosure just so
that yeah she's gonna eat the meat in
there instead of all right because so
there's always gonna be some variation
on her her needs when was released as
well so I find that sometimes was come
out hungry sometimes was down sometimes
was the thirsty
so we have to wait see right and these
are like all the stats that you can
change a little bit by messing with the
genome exactly right right all right
right right and you also make one that
was really friendly and not very
aggressive attack stats and then if you
select a Cu helicopter down there mm-hmm
you can either pilot it manually or add
a task for it for the AI to to do this
for you right
actually no I'm gonna try it and do this
manually even though it's gonna be a
disaster
I've always been horrible with aiming
these kinds of things spacebar to take
off I mean right I'm even worse with
controllers so I'll try and do this just
like this
and I think you should give it my help
Oh oh gosh so ah no why I guess the food
didn't satisfy so is there a way to get
the closer so you can actually control
the helicopter while you're here to move
physically closer me you right oh yeah I
see so you can also come out and you
know relinquish control in the Simon
task yeah that sounds like a great idea
how do you do that right and then add a
task and then put the mouse in a point
to the there we go all right yeah that's
my taking care of that and in the
meantime I think she's having a having a
little snack on me gruesome did we lose
if you right-click the mouse just to
come out thanks face god that's that's
horrible
I'm sorry I love that she still has
stats like habitat zero
I think if you click on her as well you
leave it you'll even see who killed
their souls
she was killed by a dinosaur you press
the aa key to bring up her tracking data
uh-huh
hunted down by oh right so in order to
transfer her to a new home you need to
go back to our ACU Center right and
select the transport team this time so
transport team and then we can click on
the dinosaur and and while we're also
here we can remove yeah already create
that task and they're just gonna do this
after this all right say if you do that
that's it so they'll come and they will
dispose off think oh you have got to do
their thing right it's quite nice to
watch the geysers get picked up do these
guys also move in packs like should I
get a bunch more so that well they are
social animals and some herbivores more
social than others and street smarts are
very social so having lots and lots of
them is definitely not a bad idea
right right also they're really cheap
and they think about relatively quickly
obviously the downsides being that they
don't have a particularly high dinosaur
rating a dinosaur rating is a kind of
reflection of how attractive they are
together right so you don't need that
feeder anymore so one thing you can do
is you can actually use the little
digger icon on the left and you can
demolish it and you'll get a little bit
of a refund right okay so you should
find that you're a Ceratosaurus snappy
herself was just hanging in there yeah
that is very poetic looks really strange
she says she's rag dolling away yeah
quite a bit of effort went into one sort
of nailing the ragdolls and these Navy
can I react appropriately to physics
yeah right quite lifelike
if slightly slightly sad to look at and
the graphics are really amazing I love
the way that this game looks thank you
very much especially in these weather
effects it's really cool yeah
yeah they yeah they get more impressive
alright shall we say oh I've got some
path elements on this one so if you get
like certain paths you're get certain
elements on them as well with lights and
just because these are the really cheap
paths you don't really get anything on
them yeah right so you can you can sort
of craft your own almost like Main
Street yeah yeah you have like your
restaurants and such and you could use
the fancier paths sort of as guest areas
and then for sort of operations base
things or like past leading to power
stations you know there's no reason to
use that sort of path day no that's
great it's up to you to mix and match
see oh it looks like you're streaky - is
ready to release find your source
somewhere there are many goats in here
now how'd that happen oh really wow they
just run free I don't know where she is
I think you're hiding in the trees very
well could be let's take the map oh
right Oh lots of info as you can see
over here in the building right oh and
this is the reading for the dinosaurs
like how interesting there are our
rights hasn't quite outdated book they
lose their rating when they're sedated
yeah that makes sense I think she is
Explorer yeah it doesn't seem like she's
very hungry right now
I suppose so hunting 94 percent that
means that the hunting like instinct is
all fine she doesn't really feel like
well I definitely need some kind of
platform where you can look at the
enclosure here so I could just attach
one of these here or she might just need
to clear the trees to make enough right
that makes sense
right now so let's get rid of these
there we go
lots of goats in there yeah yes what are
these so I mean means you close to your
gate it might fit just on the air we go
it's on that end I feel like oh this
might be a rotate it round because it's
just facing the wrong way oh oh right
whoops well another Mohnish it while
it's still building yes oh good so
you'll get a partial refund for that
unfortunately right right but that's
okay we're not doing too bad for money
so if you just press ed or X that will
flip flip around right there we go so
these buildings snap to the fence um but
I think again because of the trees on
that side they're causing an obstruction
so you might just need to DeForest a
little bit on there Oh fine trying to
find the right place there we go
and again as usual it just needs to get
connected to the path and you should
find actually the paths here clear away
through three forest so you can actually
create some nice sort of winding path oh
really oh I'll try that it's quite nice
I'll try that then so we've got a super
dense forest going on here
and let's just add some paths to that
then so the trick here is obviously
finding the snap point on the building
to - fix it - but yeah oh yeah there we
go alright that's that's a really
weird-looking path I guess you can
remove paths by getting another tool or
say you could you can use the knowledge
tool like you would for building and
right you can right right oh you have to
see where I can connect this all right
something like that should be good okay
so how do I break the dinosaur out of
options you can you can open the gate
uh-huh or you can oh good you can just
delete the fence dinosaurs themselves
can also escape and you know obviously
this is based on their behavior and
their needs and they could become
agitated over time and if that happens
they can actually start attacking the
fence road and eventually break out now
your goats convincing
Oh God Oh God that goat is directly
leading the dinosaur out of the
enclosure that makes a lot of sense yeah
there she is no she's out snap he's
headed
she decided she's gonna go for a bit of
an explore unless that's okay I was
hoping that she was gonna eat some
guests no offense to the guests but it
looks like she's not really hungry yet
yeah something's catched her caught her
interest rather right ah that's really
cool I guess he's trying to like explore
the outer rim of the enclosure she's
really sticking to the fence that's
interesting actually like the AI of the
dinosaurs because in the films like
they're quite intelligent and they can
figure out a lot of stuff since that
also men worked into the game yes I mean
primarily their behaviour based on their
on their needs first and they obviously
react different stimuli they they sort
of have almost like an agenda there's
something they want to do they're gonna
they're gonna do it right but primarily
it's driven by their their needs at any
given time and so what you would
normally do if you got dinosaur escaped
and you were sort of clever enough to
build some guest shelters mm-hmm you
would open your shelters declare a sort
of emergency state in the park so you
guess would try and flee to your
shelters mm-hmm that helps minimize sort
of her guest dinosaur interactions right
and then you would want to send or usual
ACU team as each race you teams who were
tranquilizer Dan sort of so you could
safely return to the enclosure right
right but she looks like she doesn't
want to play ball she looks like she's
just happy to explore mate I know she's
not actually seen guests yet I could be
true you know she doesn't notice that
they're there but the guests are
certainly starting to notice that she's
there really they kind of make a break
for it yeah
they've kind of got far enough away that
they don't think she's a threat but
you'll find that they I think there's a
couple of guys just coming down the path
over there yeah turn around and go the
other way so yeah it is interesting to
see though that they're not entirely
vicious killers they don't just like go
out and destroy everything kind of keep
acting the way they normally do but if
they're hungry then you might get into
some trouble so yeah if she's not angry
she's just she's just curious and ready
I can change
yeah they very well might but how she
noticed the guests yet I think she has
she's seeing someone there can tell it's
her I don't think so yeah that's a bit
of an anti-climax for now although
although I'm definitely glad that people
haven't died yeah lots of life avoided
and eventually somewhere in the game you
can get the t-rex right that's got to be
a little bit more dangerous for other
people on the pike is a big big draw
yeah obviously the more guests you bring
to park the more things there are to
work to munch on yeah yeah right and the
guests are also gonna like sort of react
to it like they'll run away from the
dinosaurs again that sort of stuff
happens if you've got shelters they're
all and they're open on the play to do
that's a manual manual option manual
interaction should I say mmm-hmm you
need to actually open your shelters for
them too you have to flee into it right
right I think that's all the time we've
got all right that's been fun yeah it's
been a lot of fun itself I have never
even actually really thought about the
video but like it's been super
informative and super fun Seikaly check
this out what's the first time so I'm
really glad alright so that was the
gameplay and I know that might have
seemed quite long but honestly in real
life it felt way too short about an hour
is hardly any time to figure anything
out
but I do have to say there are a couple
of things that definitely stood out to
me for one the fact that I managed to do
quite a bit in an hour despite being
completely new to this game and not
knowing much about it obviously I had a
developer on my side to help me with
anything but generally I think this game
is really intuitive the UI looks really
great but besides that it works quite
well as well and everything is just kind
of easy to figure out if you've played
any game that's remotely similar to this
kind of deal and it's just in general
there's nothing really too complicated
about this there are some things which I
believe I kindly discussed in this and I
also discussed a little bit I believe in
my interview which I had later which
should also be on my channel is that
there are some things which players to
have to kinda figure out themselves like
the way that the AI works or the way
that you have to put certain dinosaurs
together but that's just kind of part of
the experience as well all the basic
level I think it's quite an easy game to
learn also and this is a topic which it
probably should have started with
because it's something that stood out to
me most the graphics are really amazing
they're just as good as I was hoping
them to be based on some of the really
rendered images that we saw in earlier
trailers so that is a huge plus about
this game definitely some of the first
shots that we were shown at the events
during a demo which was public I sort of
noticed that I was forgetting that I was
looking at actual in-game shots rather
than just cinematic shots that were
pre-rendered or something like that and
the same it's kind of the reason why
I've really stated in the video at some
points that you are looking at actual
in-game shots and it's just in-game
footage where you can move the camera
around and do whatever even if it looks
super cinematic and really real you can
definitely tell that it's in the same
engine as planet coaster or some very
big similarities in terms of graphics
but overall it's it's much better it
looks much better obviously and this is
one of the things which
for me very honestly is a bit of a - I
guess because it's something which I am
into there is not much creativity
involved in the game it's really focused
on management and this is probably also
why the graphics are honestly this good
since you don't really have much options
when it comes to building things the
path work system is amazing I'm
definitely a huge fan of the paths but
aside from that you don't really get to
do much with the buildings obviously I
don't know how much this is gonna change
up to the final release of the game and
to what extent you know you get
different looking islands etc but
generally it seems like it'll focus a
lot on management and that's really
something to expect out of this so if
you're only into these kinds of games
just for creativity then I don't think
it'll be quite the thing for you but
even then I think it is quite easy to
get used to for people who haven't done
this kind of thing yet since it was
quite easy to get used to for me and
there are also some other smaller things
I think the dinosaurs look absolutely
amazing animation is great that just
kind of fits into the whole category of
graphics in general but obviously since
this is a dinosaur game you definitely
want to make sure that those things just
look amazing and they absolutely do and
some of the general tools some of the
smaller things are also great I think
the terraforming system as simple as it
is it's just basic terraforming tools is
everything that you basically want it to
be it's nothing more but it's good and I
think the fence tool is for me one of
those small things which you don't
really think about beforehand but while
you play the game you realize it's
actually genius the way that you can
curve fences and how easy it is to place
fences and create these enclosures is
absolutely amazing so big surprises in a
positive way for me there and as for the
storyline it seems like the storyline is
gonna play quite a big role in the game
since everything will be management and
really storyline driven I actually had
this really interesting conversation
with the writer for the game where it
just kind of found outside the booth and
had some really amazing stories to tell
this but the the storyline is is
something which really drives the game
in the end I think and it's not just you
get plopped into a random setting and
have to come up with your own park or
you get some random list of some sort of
objectives that you have to meet up to
there's a real script and there's some
pretty good voice acting so it's really
interesting to see that as well and yeah
that's really most of my basic thoughts
most of all for myself I am very curious
to see how much I'll actually be into
this game I think it'll be a good game
at least what I've seen so far if this
if this trend goes for the rest of the
game is to keep up this quality I think
it'll be a a fine game but for me
personally I'm just not sure how much it
is up in my LE
since even though I am into management
for me creativity is a huge part of that
as well and that's the sort of specific
gameplay that I am personally looking
for you might not see it in my planet
coaster or City skylines videos because
it's not something that my youtube
channel is really based on but I've
always been a huge fan of games like
rollercoaster tycoon or even more
obscure things like the ski resort
Tycoon or just Zoo Tycoon SimCity all
that sort of stuff kind of 50/50 because
of management on one hand and creativity
on the other and I think this this game
might very well focus more on management
and way less on creativity so whether
I'll actually like it is something that
honestly I'm gonna reserve until the
release of the game but so far I think
what I've seen at least suggests that
this will be a good game so yeah those
were basically my thoughts let me know
what you guys think in the description
especially if you're coming over from
maybe the planet coaster or City
skylines community because I'm really
interested in what kind of thoughts
you'd be having about this game coming
from kind of the same perspective as I
do and I would like to thank everybody
for watching and I hope to you guys
either in the next video whenever that's
gonna be or perhaps in the interview
video which I will be publishing today
as well in which I get to interview some
devs of the game so yeah that's it for
now
bye guys